today is Super Tuesday as I mentioned a
huge day for the presidential primary
elections and here to talk about his
experience voting which apparently a lot
of you haven't had here to talk about
his experience voting is one of our
writers let's get him out here Levi's
MacDougall
that's here
all right hey yeah how'd it go with me
if I take on him pretty good hey
everyone
I'd hoped you'd all voted today you know
it is a truly one of the great
privileges of being part of a democracy
really makes me proud every time I pull
that big lever okay well wait
sounds like you enjoyed your voting
experience today Levi enough yeah I
loved it Conan I had my trusty voting
guide with me inside that secret chamber
double check to make sure there were no
hanging chads just a great all-around
vote time I'm sorry Levi you just said
hanging chads I don't think any polling
centers here use that kind of ballot
anymore where did you vote Oh
same place as everyone yeah I just
plugged vote station into Google Maps
and went where it told me yeah that's
not how it works you should have an
assigned polling center everyone does
yeah totally yeah you know and then I
got there and I just flipped through one
of those big vote binders you know
handed my selections to the DJ and just
waited to hear my candidates name wait
are you sure that you voted Levi oh yeah
big time I blasted off hey I even got a
little woozy afterwards from all the
voting excitement but luckily they give
you that cookie and a couple of like a
cup of apple juice so you know let's
rock the vote hey guys wait a minute
Levi I just remembered you're Canadian
aren't you you're Canadian hold it can
you even vote here yeah well like all
the time it's easy for me
Levi I'm sorry but no you cannot vote
here yeah and I'm sorry it looks like
you made that I voted sticker get in on
that that doesn't love her
oh okay yeah okay you win I'm I'm not
officially a US citizen so I can't vote
okay I just saw all these people posting
selfies with their I voted stickers and
I don't know I just wanted to see what
it felt like you know I guess I never
realized how our elections make
Canadians in this country feel yeah
that's the problem
no one does you don't know how it feels
to be the only one who's Tuesday wasn't
super cuz I'm from Saskatchewan aren't
you from Alberta I can't vote today
there is no legal way for a lonely boy
like me to make his mark on history
cuz I'm Canadian you see well that's um
that's really beautiful Levi can you get
off my stage please security secure to
get Levi out
come on buddy get out of here I'm sorry
I can't I know exactly how to be the
only one
for I also cannot vote cuz I'm a
convicted felon
Wow was it like something pretty bad
yeah it was pretty bad we can't vote
today to sadboys without a say no
stickers for these fools his I'm
Canadian
[Music]
[Applause]
feel it for you guys beautiful and what
I'm going to give you a sticker you
already did
yeah you are in that sticker yeah
[Applause]